[Music]
not coming on to you yet but I'm
noticing Vince that I admire the cut of
your jib you've you've gotten yourself
in very good shape I think that's true
and you can't help but notice yes yeah
it's confusing because I was in a fight
now I'm in a different kind of energy
I'm gonna say yes to all of it like
switch it up I like it that's how I roll
but have you been what's your regimen
what have you been doing because you
look like you've been taking real good
care yourself you know what it was and I
appreciate that I appreciate the what
your eyes are telling your mind and then
what your mouth is telling you with that
but for me I just got up when my wife
had the baby I kind of just hung out too
and gained a little weight now I've been
a little bit more active so it's nice to
feel a little healthier I remember
talking you one time and you were on all
that you told me you're on a lion diet
that's right I was on a lion diet what
is the lion diet is what one says it
themselves when they're wanting to eat
whatever they want I'll put you this way
I said to myself and do of you exercise
a little bit that day you start to feel
like well I can eat whatever I want
today I did you know it could be nothing
20 minutes 30 minutes on a treadmill but
you say I did something right so I would
have the caloric intake of Michael
Phelps yeah
but then I would have the exercise
output of like you know a a you know
older executive so I wasn't matching the
calories with the burning off of the
stuff now the lion diet that like sounds
like something that you would just
instantly want to do it sounds like
something like like moonshine like you
don't know exactly what moonshine is
either but it sounds like you want to
drink it for the rest of your life and
like the lion diets like yeah I can't
afford not to be on the lion that sounds
like you yeah you just gorge yourself or
Janelle you sleep in the Sun the concept
you said well the reason I got the
concept was I said you never really see
an overweight lion that's what it was
right when I said a lion isn't picky
about what a lion eats a lion eats what
it can get right and overeat and then
the line will enjoy a nice nap then
relax
so I think maybe we're overthinking this
maybe if I do a little of activity I can
eat whatever I want to eat as the lion
does not translate well to me what about
you Owen what's your technique are you a
guy that you know you you're always in
good shape Oh fellow well I'm not on the
lion diet but probably just kind of the
usual stuff try to kind of stay active
and everything one thing people may not
know about Owen is he'll isolate his
bottom for about 20 minutes a day blue
sky just do glue doctor so yeah that's
all he'll do he'll he'll do the fire
hydrant he'll touch sky he'll point the
toe he'll just literally work up his ass
for 22 it's room I sequester my bottom
he punishes his bottom and it's a gift
for everybody else that's what he does
gentlemen I feel like I shouldn't do
this I've been talking about food a lot
but there is a website called
celebrities eating food and there's a
section called celebrities pounding it
in which it's a candid shot of you two
enjoying ice cream and as usual show it
now
guys on the Lion
those liens have heard that I scream
hurry the buildings on fire I don't know
that there is an elegant way to eat some
ice cream but I'll be damned if I'm
going to be intimidated out of some ice
cream by by this website right I'll
enjoy I'll enjoy a cone right now yeah I
hate when people get down on the
internet and say it's not a force for
good and then you see that you're like
yes the information of been disseminate